good morning believe nation today's
message is make your customers dreams
come true over to you Arthur Blank you
know to me it was always about you know
understanding what the customers were
coming from trying to satisfy their
needs making their dreams come true
making their problems go away and we
knew if we did the right things to
support those kind of values at the end
of the day we're going to produce the
kind of financial results that we did
which were great for our shareholders
great for our associates great for our
investors and great for the communities
that we serve in terms of giving back in
a variety of ways I think it's really
important message because so many
entrepreneurs that I find are just
starting the business trying to make a
lot of money and that is not the path to
success really what you want to do is
think about your customers right think
about what your customers want think
about what their biggest pain points are
with their biggest needs are and solve
it for them right what dreams and
ambitions and desires do they have and
how can you be a part of a solution and
doing that will make you not just a lot
of money but also make you feel good
like you are adding value to the world
you are helping somebody's life become
better I look at Toronto dance houses
where I am right now the the TDS studio
and the the mantra here is all about
family and you look at people who come
nobody comes to this school trying to
become the best salsa dancer in the
world right people come for a variety of
reasons people come because they want to
meet somebody people come because they
want to develop new friends people come
because they want to stay fit people
come because they're bored with their
life you know a lot of the people who
come this is a highlight of them for the
week right this is something that they
look forward to because they're they may
not be growing in their regular life and
this is a way for them to grow and learn
and meet somebody and have fun and be a
part of a community and when we
recognize that then it's not just about
how much can we charge for a class how
much money can we take from these people
right it's much more about if we can
give them a positive experience if we
can connect them with other people
if we can make them feel like they're
learning and growing they're going to
want to come back and that's a service
that people will pay for and then we've
just extended the business based on the
needs and wants and the dreams of our
customers so as an example it started
off just being salsa classes right you
come you learn a class you come for one
hour week people found that they wanted
time to practice in between they wanted
more social aspect to it they wanted to
connect with other people so we started
hosting what are called socials where
every Wednesday night we have a bachata
social every Sunday night we have a
salsa social and then twice a month we
do a party at a local club and it's just
basically an opportunity for people to
come practice our moves meet each other
have fun connect with other students and
just have a deeper and more rich
experience through our salsa classes and
that's an opportunity to make more money
to write like people come when they pay
to come these events but the reason to
do it was hey how can we milk more money
out of our customers right how can we
increase our revenue it was one of the
problems that our students are having
actually make our customers dream comes
true when a lot of them have gone on you
know I met Nina through salsa Alex who's
been on the channel is in my operations
manager actually just proposed to his
girlfriend on New Year's Eve so he met
his now fiance through salsa right where
people are losing a lot of way people
are making new friends people feel like
they have meaning and purpose people are
having a lot of fun and we're making
their dreams come true when were
profiting from it but it's the reason
they get into it isn't because we're
just trying to make a lot of money we're
trying to help our customers and by
doing that you end up making a lot of
money so the question today today is how
do you make your customers dreams come
true leave it in the comments below I'm
really curious to see what you guys are
going to write and I will join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events press 0
when espresso TV go